it's bigger than the pictures it's also
a little more norman bates
key house is mostly fantasy only half
the home's exterior is real from filming
in canada to creating complicated
interiors the show's team worked magic
on these sets
who wants to see inside
me
okay let's go
lock and key is set in the fictional
town of matheson massachusetts but to
get the small town vibes right filming
didn't go anywhere near new england
instead the picturesque lunenburg a port
town in nova scotia canada doubles as
the quaint historic village where the
lock family relocates if you visit the
town you'll be able to walk the same
streets as the show's characters founded
in 1753 lunenburg is considered a unesco
world heritage site up to 70 percent of
the town's 18th and 19th century
colonial buildings are still standing
since the show goes back to the
revolutionary war getting the colonial
setting right was very important
i've always wanted to see this place
while the town of matheson is in nova
scotia key house was built somewhere
entirely different the home's exterior
set was constructed on an estate near
hamilton ontario but the crew didn't
build the entire house instead only two
floors of the front facade were
assembled and the rest of the house was
added later with cgi the entrance to the
house is still real and you can actually
walk inside it's movie magic baby
however you won't find any sign of the
lock family's home instead there's just
some set pieces storage and makeup
touch-up stations the cast and crew
would also head inside to keep warm the
key house may not be in nova scotia but
the small canadian town did serve as
inspiration for its design the design
team took some notes from blue nose
lodge a historic inn in lunenburg
constructed in 1863.
the cast and crew had to travel once
again to film scenes inside keyhouse the
house's interiors were created on a
sound stage at toronto's cinespace film
studios and packed full of hidden
details the mysteries of the house seem
to be endless executive producer carlton
hughes explained the challenge of
creating the sets in an interview with
cbr when we adapted it for production we
had to make it really functional and
practical a lot of attention was paid to
the home's layout creating circularities
so that the characters had paths to walk
where the camera could easily follow
them rory cheney was the show's
production designer and according to one
of the show's directors michael morris
he went all out with small details in
the home even down to hiding the kh
initials of keyhouse throughout the
wooden moldings the director refers to
the manor as a puzzle box you can unfold
the show's a mystery so there had to be
plenty of places for things to be hidden
and discovered your house is filled with
amazing keys
while key house may not be entirely real
the well house was really built in the
countryside not far from the home's
exterior set are you my echo
keyhouse's yard was made to look wild
and unruly while filming in canada was
plenty cold the set designers added
details like fake cotton snow which
looks incredibly believable for such a
simple practical set dressing but if you
continue down the path you'll make your
way to the very real wellhouse
of course a lot of attention was paid to
detail here like how the intricate
pattern of the ceilings is identical to
the pattern on the echo key the actors
were able to film their scenes on this
set while cgi was added later to make
things seem more eerie and creepy and to
make the well look bottomless why are
you down there echoes can come to life
in this place you likely noticed that
key house's layout is pretty chaotic the
outside of the home isn't balanced or
symmetrical and inside there's no rhyme
or reason to how the rooms are organized
this was done entirely on purpose
gabriel rodriguez who did the artwork
for the comic book series was trained as
an architect he treated the design of
keyhouse as an architectural challenge
he wanted it to be as uneven and
unsymmetrical as possible from every
point of view he even ended up drawing
architectural blueprints of the house to
make it believable while keyhouse was
supposed to be a bit intimidating
director michael morris wanted to make
sure it wasn't too scary he told decider
that he aimed to make it dilapidated but
not menacing there's a lot of things to
discover throughout the home but he
wanted it to be more inviting than other
haunted horror stories like the haunting
of hill house do you think the house is
scary or just interesting going to a new
school starting in the middle of the
year might suck but also it might not
scenes that took place at the show's
high school matheson academy were filmed
at the humber college lakeshore campus
located on the shores of lake ontario
this college might actually be the
closest to a haunting the show had to
experience in real life the neo-gothic
building is considered to be one of
toronto's most haunted places the
grounds of the college were once home to
an asylum and there have been hundreds
of reports of people seeing apparitions
in or around the college these ghosts
have been especially associated with the
underground tunnels on campus we wonder
if any of the cast experienced something
supernatural while on set i think we're
starting to see how that begins
while most matheson academy scenes were
really filmed in a school the school's
cafeteria wasn't really a cafeteria at
all it's actually the library of an
anglican school in toronto called
wycliffe college the books were removed
and long wooden tables were brought in
for filming the elegant building is
located at the university of toronto's
st george campus the school was founded
in 1877
and we can definitely see the similarity
to schools like cambridge and oxford
which helped inspire other great school
sets like those in harry potter which
begs the question is any school age
fantasy series really complete without
an epic meal haul
how is any of this possible i told you
it's the keys
while the interior sets are almost
entirely done in studios there are
plenty of real-life places you can visit
if you're a big fan of the show several
exterior scenes in matheson were filmed
in lunenburg including the ice cream
parlor which is a real ice cream shop
called sweet treasures confectionary you
can even grab lunch or spend the night
at the salt shaker deli and inn that
appears in the show's first episode it's
located right across the street from the
ice cream shop
you can also check out the theater where
the splattering premiered the exterior
shots of the premiere were filmed at the
west dale movie theater in hamilton
ontario which doubled for the fictional
strand theater however the interior
scenes were filmed elsewhere at
hamilton's playhouse cinema
now this is cool i mean kind of scary
but really cool
it's easy to imagine that all the epic
cliffside locations seen in the tv show
were created using cgi but some of them
were actually real like the drowning
caves the exterior of the caves was very
real and was filmed at ovens natural
park in nova scotia however the creepy
cave interiors were created just for the
show these scenes were filmed near the
key house interior sets on the cinespace
film studios soundstage other cliffs
that appear in the series weren't so
real the cliffside house where kinsey
goes to meet gabe has a real front
facade but cgi was used to make it hang
precariously over the edge
we're in bath
happy birthday jack
the anywhere key can take you well
anywhere but it's not quite so easy in
real life
when tyler takes jackie to bath a quaint
english city filming didn't really head
all the way to the uk
there wouldn't be a good reason for
filming to head to england just for a
few short scenes so just like they
created a small massachusetts town in
nova scotia they did the same thing for
the english city they actually just used
stock footage for the first few
establishing shots
but the walk by the river was filmed in
mill race park in cambridge ontario the
other scenes in the english town were
all filmed at springer market square in
kingston ontario so the cast and crew
didn't have to travel too far for their
little english journey with the magical
key
if i do get back that anywhere key
i'm coming straight to nebraska the work
that went into making lock and key
believable yet uniquely imaginative is
incredible especially when you consider
that there were two adaptations in the
works before the netflix series they
never panned out because key house was
just so hard to design so let us know
which of the movie's real life sets
would you want to visit most